[Music]
from sacha javid to zara sultana
politicians from the right and left have
attacked jimmy carr for a joke he made
about the holocaust in his latest comedy
show
for context here's what he said
when people talk about the holocaust
they talk about the tragedy and horror
of six million jewish lives being lost
to the nazi war machine but they never
mention the thousands of gypsies that
were killed by the nazis no one ever
wants to talk about that because no one
ever wants to talk about the positives
[Applause]
in his column for the magazine this week
douglas murray says that while carr is
quote one of the comedians i dislike the
most and despite the joke being quote
cruel and unwitty government regulation
was set a dangerous precedent to explain
douglas joins me now
douglas in this week's magazine you
write about jimmy carr what do you make
from the fallout from his netflix
special
well there's several very interesting
things about it um
one of them
is that uh jimmy carr i'm not a fan of
his um i'm sort of standing up for his
right to make
um
jokes including
unpleasant jokes uh but what i think is
happening here is first of all is what
what is known as context collapse where
an in-group's conversation is discovered
by an out group jimmy carr's audience
know exactly what they're getting when
they go to his shows is one reason i
don't go to his shows i don't think you
like what he offers but his his audience
his fans know what they're getting when
they go to his shows or when they click
on his netflix special um
what's happened this past week has been
that an out group has discovered a part
of this material
one joke from his show his dark material
was excerpted sent around on twitter and
he was then subjected to the inevitable
uh five minutes of hate
which follows it's a very typical story
um
and
i think that the most worrying bit of it
is actually not the public or
twittersphere reaction which is as
deranging and deranged as it always is
the most disturbing thing is that
government ministers once again have
felt that they need to intervene and say
what they think should be joked about
and what should not
yes so the culture secretary nadine
doris has said that the joke was
shocking and has suggested that the
government would be looking at ways to
sanction outlets like netflix if they
were to publish this sort of thing i
can't help but feel this is going to go
badly badly wrong
yeah
as ever with politicians you get this
horrible feeling like we've not
discussed free speech before works in
britain we've discussed it for centuries
and we know the parameters and we know
the problems and we know the risks and
we know the rewards um
but yes the idea that nadine doris feels
compelled to speak about this and of
course she's
culture secretary she's actually
potentially got some sway on it sajid
javid once again strangely it's another
intervention from him in uh the free
speech issue has has also uh condemned
what does the health secretary have to
do with deciding what content netflix
should or shouldn't put out what jokes
people should or shouldn't say and then
you've got the the worst person of all
is totally uh unheard of previously snp
counselor of course it's someone from
the snp who had less understanding of
freedom than perhaps anybody else in the
country but it's an snp counselor who
has called not just for the prosecution
of of jimmy carr for hate speech but the
prosecution of his audience for laughing
i mean this is just
as i say maybe we can just you know
ignore it because it's an snp counselor
but it's very worrying that anyone uh in
any position of power at all in this
country has such a lack of understanding
of basic freedoms that they think you
should be able to prosecute people for
being caught laughing at the wrong
material it's pathetic
well douglas to go back to jimmy carr
you write in your column that if you
find a joke distasteful if you find a
comedian distasteful there's a really
easy way of handling this and that's
just don't tune in don't watch them
do you think there's ever a time where a
joke can go too far in which just saying
i'm tuning out i'm not paying attention
isn't quite good enough
oh i think jokes go far too far all the
time
one of the points of comedy in the
society is to try to work out where
those points are
another point by the way of comedy is to
help us deal with very unpleasant and
ugly things about life you know the old
saying you know if you didn't
if you didn't laugh you'd cry comes from
a very basic recognition about comedy
which is that it helps us through
horrible ugly dark things now i think
some comedians are very very adept at uh
at finding their way through that jimmy
carter gave him credit i said i'm not an
admirer of his particular given credit
isn't bad at navigating some of that
there are much better people ricky
gervais for instance but i mean the
history of comedy is of of people trying
to find their way through the maze of of
current taboos and and and much more and
so of course people can go too far but
the other point about that is they can
go too far for certain audiences as i
say again
it's about this ingrid group thing um
a particular audience knows what they're
going to get
and an outside audience may not be aware
of that at all this is happening not
just with comedy it's happening with
literature and much more but i think
that it's strange that in our era
comedians keep on uh
becoming the sort of brunt of these
strange stampedes that happen recently
with a far more talented comedian than
jimmy carr which is dave chappelle in
the states
and the reason why it's happening as i
say is because comedians are meant to
explore difficult material
douglas one really interesting part of
your column was where you talk about
ricky gervais and a joke that he has
made about anne frank and you say in the
column that you think he was just on the
right side of the line you think he just
got away with it but you also say that
you probably have to be jewish or making
a deeper point in order to make a joke
like that and i'm curious do you think
that that is the case when it comes to
humor for all forms of identity
yes i i think so i think that it's i
think that it's
a comedian has to earn the trust of his
audience to allow for them to allow him
or her to go to transgressive places now
the obvious thing is that is that an
audience is more likely to trust the
particular comedian that they're going
to go to those places and be
trustworthy as it were if that person
already is clearly not for instance
beating up on a particular minority for
the sake of them being a minority the
most obvious example is um there are
things that black comedians are able to
say which white comedians are not there
are things that jewish comedians are
able to say that non-jewish comedians
are not and and i i give this example in
the piece about you know as it were
jokes about the holocaust because there
are some jewish jokes about the
holocaust um
and it's a sort of sub genre and it's
and it's
it's a very very complex terrain but one
of the one of the things that that has
existed in in what jokes there are about
the holocaust is
um an attempt not just to deal with the
horror
but to but to say something about it i
give an example in the piece of
a joke of of um uh two people two men
killed in the holocaust they're in
heaven they're talking uh they're
laughing about something that happened
in the camps
and they're laughing so much they
attract the attention of god who's
passing by and and god stops and he says
my children my children how can you
laugh at
such things
and one of them says to god uh
i guess you had to be there
now i mean that that that's that's a
joke with a heck of a punch
and uh it has a real
real point to it now i think again uh uh
um
if audiences have to feel a confidence
that the comedian is is doing something
that and and has their trust the example
i give for the ricky gervais joke about
anne frank which i i thought as they say
and the piece that you just quoted was
was just about from the borderline was
i said i'm not quite sure you've earned
the right to do that in other words i
sort of think a long and you know
a very elderly comedian preferably
jewish could potentially get away with
that joke but you have sort of trust you
have to trust them now is it well i i
trust ricky gervais on that but but that
that trust element with the audience is
incredibly important but but this is
this is about the sort of finery of of
comedy and comedy techniques and
what i worry about is a much broader
thing which is comedians keep on getting
it at the moment because of their
they're at the forefront of some of the
free speech issues of our time and the
absolutely central issue of our time on
this is a deep misunderstanding or at
least uncertainty in our societies about
what is speech and what is action
and uh this this sort of condemnation of
jimmy carr for this this i think very
tasteless and unfunny joke
seems to me to be constantly not just by
the idiot snp counselor but by others as
well
confused with action you know these are
words they are it is a joke and you
either laugh or you don't it's not the
same as action and uh we've sort of told
ourselves in our age that speech and
action are so close to each other
that you have to you have to always
stand down on the speech otherwise
action will inevitably follow and i
don't think that is the case i think
it's very lazy
and as i say uh toward the end of the
piece i think one of the reasons why
these he's sort of stamping on the
comedians is happening is because it it
is quite easy in the court to hang the
jester it's much easier than ruling land
justly or wisely
and i think that our ministers and even
our councillors should reflect on that
and douglas netflix so far have not
taken down the jimmy carr special in the
age of cancelled culture it feels like
not taking something down feels like a
bit of a win for free speech but i'm
curious as to how this compares to
spotify and joe rogan while i have you
here i'd love to know what you think of
what's been happening to him and i know
that you've been on his show a few times
yeah i admire joe enormously he's a
seriously talented comedian and an
unbelievably talented podcast
um i don't think people realize unless
they've seen it done badly
what did what it involved to be as good
a at what he does as joe is uh it's
quite amazing to have sort of multi-hour
conversations it's completely gripping
he he has he has trust of his audience
and again it comes back to the same
thing it's an ingroup out group thing uh
joe rogan has a larger following than
any commercial television channel
and a lot of the old media have been
gunning for joe and they've been doing
it
through very typical means again
selecting certain things
that they believe are being said that
the people in the conversation know are
not being said so
the bbc and others this week just ran
the story claiming that joe rogan has
had to apologize for racist language in
the past they they imply that joe rogan
has been a racist in the past and has
been caught using racist language and
this isn't the case at all and all of
joe rogan's followers know that he's the
furthest person from being a racist you
could possibly be it's an absurd and
obscene accusation uh but the but the
allegation is made because on occasions
in the past they found times when he has
used the n-word in the context of
quoting somebody using the n-word and
and now there is a total prohibition on
even
uh
people saying that
and uh and that is quite different from
somebody throwing around racist language
and calling people you know vile racist
terms so so the old media has tried to
just to to destroy this absolute um
top figure in the new media i think it
won't work i think spotify are
absolutely right to stand beside him
should stand beside him and not just for
commercial reasons but for very obvious
uh strategic and moral ones because if
you allow the mob to take out somebody
as as important as as impressive as joe
rogan it'll take out absolutely
everybody next so um spotify should
absolutely stand uh behind him i'm glad
they have so far uh i hope that netflix
stand up for jimmy carter i hope that
everybody stands up for their mates i
hope that everyone stands up for the
right of people to make jokes and to
explore difficult things uh and
obviously this is partly as you know
kate an issue of self-interest as well
because after they after they've
got rid of all of the comedians they'll
be coming for the writers and
journalists and uh you and i better
watch out backs well douglas i very much
hope that everybody reads your column
this week in the spectator magazine
thanks for joining me
[Music]
you